good evening counselors counselor
sewers will suppress dear God
we seek your help with our affairs today
bless this meeting with your
intelligence and help us to make the
best use of our own we are of diverse
opinion here yet we wish to mend our
differences and reach agreement
satisfactory to all please share a
little of your wisdom with us to help us
to do right by all concerned in Jesus
name army
welcome to this first meeting of the
council my first of all remind you of
some domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet a little switch town football
club training pick do not re-enter the
building until you are told it's safe to
do so please switch off all mobile
phones or turn to silent I would like to
remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
Internet and be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you'll
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed by entering
this room you are also consenting to
being filmed by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded finally can members
and officers please ensure that you
press the microphone for speaking and
turn off when you finish right I'll move
to the agenda now apologies for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies so far for councillor none and
counts to Cresswell thank you any other
policies
to dispensation to all members for item
BC nineteen seven draft local joint
local plan are there any other
declarations of interest thank you
move to item three BC nineteen five to
confirm the minutes of the annual
meeting held on 22nd May 2019 for
accuracy only are there any issues with
accuracy please could I have a proposer
please John Ward thank you could I have
a seconder
Adrienne Osborn thank you can we take a
vote for the for the minutes please
except ten minutes
carried thank you point for CC 96
announcements from the Chairman and
leader I have no announcements other
than what's in paper deceive 19:6 for
noting Thank You councillor Ward
anything to report Thank You chairman I
thought I'd take this opportunity to
bright provide you all with a brief
update on what the District Council's
network has been doing on behalf of
districts and boroughs in the country as
you will be aware there are many
pressing issues for local government and
it is gratifying to note that there is
widespread consensus irrespective of who
controls the council's about what we
require from central government and our
frustrations that there is continuing
uncertainty and delay over progress with
funding and a finance settlement the DCN
Board meeting that took place on the 5th
of June was the first since the
elections and covered a lot of ground
and so I just thought I'd give you a
quick update a few of the key items and
we noted that a number of permitted
development changes to encourage greater
flexibility for the use of Town Center
buildings
to affect last month also the government
is now considering the initial
expressions of interest for the future
high street funds submitted by local
authorities earlier in the year and the
DCN will be lobbying for early decisions
on these the continued slow speed of
progress on how the housing
infrastructure fund bids buy homes
England remains a source of frustration
to many dcn members to briefing papers
were prepared for the Planning Minister
in May on speeding the build out of
consented housing sites and also on the
housing land supply the Environment
Select Committee invited the DCN to
provide evidence on the implications of
the waste strategy for local authorities
following a written evidence submission
and I have to report that none of us
whoever controls the council's likes the
free garden waste collection proposal
written evidence was submitted to the MH
CLG inquiry into local oven finance and
spending in review and also file written
response to the Treasury select
committee inquiry on the impact of
business rates on business was also
submitted following the lifting of the
housing revenue account pouring cap the
DCN commissioned a study of its impact
since implementation and to gain an
understanding of what is needed for
districts to fully explore its potential
this is a particular interest of Baber
amid Suffolk and the findings are
relevant to us the initial headline
findings are that lifting the HRA cap
has freed up a significant number of
stock holding councils and about
two-thirds in fact of the stock holding
councils to increase their house
building programs however there are
ongoing barriers to building or using
the increased borrowing and these
include the impact of the right to buy
and the affordability of schemes making
future revenues more precarious the cost
and availability of land the appetite
for borrowing and risk particularly
amongst elected members and also linked
and perceptions of capacity to deliver
effectively and finally there is the
impact of competition with the private
sector so as you can see there has a lot
been a lot going on and the DCN is being
listened to by central government which
is good moving on and on to Bellevue you
will have seen in the press press
releases recently about the official
opening of the new skate park and
multi-use games area and Bellevue Park
that took place on Saturday
there were a lot of people there to
enjoy the party we put on by all
accounts everyone thoroughly enjoyed it
Babur has invested a hundred and fifty
thousand pounds on these two facilities
and further improvements are being
planned this shows that we are committed
to the park and are not neglecting it
despite ill-founded comments in the
press and online and finally later this
week I'll be going on a dcn study tour 2
rue Solara in Belgium which has
implemented many of the recommendations
in the 2013 drusy review into the future
of the high street the DCN will use the
publication following the tour and I'll
provide a report at next month's council
meeting Thank You chairman Thank You
councillor Ward moving on to item 5 to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance of council procedural rules
Thank You chair we received two
petitions of the first 277 ballot
signatures regarding planning
application DC 19-0 1712 into intuition
and the second was a hundred and
forty-four valid signatures regarding
planning application DC 1901 873 in
Boxford thank you thank you questions by
the public in accordance with council
procedure rules none received chair
thank you item 7 questions by
councillors in accordance with council
procedure rules none received chair
thank you item 8 BC 19:7 Weber amid
Suffolk draft joint legal plan preferred
options before I invite Council Aarthi
to introduce the report would like to
remind council that the report is as it
stands before going out to consultation
apart from typographical and factual
errors membership focus on the policies
within the report and avoid getting into
any specific issues relating to members
Ward's those matters
raised and fed in as part of the
consultation thank you I would like to
invite kalfa Aarthi cabinet member for
planning to introduce paper BC 19:7 and
to move the recommendations in the
report Thank You Council Aarthi Thank
You chairman members you have in front
of you the draft local plan preferred
options document it is the second
regulation 18 stage following the
options consultation in 2017 you may
remember we had originally intended
being at this stage over two years ago
and I have been myself I have been a
fierce critic of the much-delayed
progress of the new local plan I'm
pleased to be able to bring this draft
document to my first council meeting as
cabinet member for planning but I cannot
take much credit for something that has
required a great deal of work over a
long period of time and particularly
since the options consultation stage of
two years ago this plan has been
informed by the responses to that
consultation by developing evidence base
and by the latest NPP F we must have a
compliance and up-to-date plan the
strategic policies in the first part of
the plan and the development management
policies in the second part have been
through a series of local plan working
group meetings and the whole document
was the subject of last Friday's
briefing session for members as I'm sure
you are aware the joint local plan
provides for 7500 new homes in Baber
which equates to 420 a year and the
third part of the plan suggests areas
where they could be built this part of
the plan includes the site allocations
and maps
I'm sure members were welcome policies
that address issues such as the
environment sustainability and energy
provision but will be particularly
interested in the provision of
affordable housing and infrastructure
requirements the plan incorporates
evidence from the infrastructure
delivery plan
which will be published alongside the
proposed consultation you are not being
asked to approve this plan for adoption
I'm asking you to approve it for
consultation during that consultation
you may well be involved in preparing or
helping others to prepare responses that
might be individual residents
communities parish councils and various
groups and organizations the
consultation is open to everyone and in
due course when all the responses have
been considered you will then have the
next stage in the production of the new
joint local plan the draft submission
version in front of you for approval
some people have suggested this is not
ready to go out yet but as I have said
this is a consultation stage not a final
submission a couple of months delay now
we'll just add a couple of months to the
final adoption of the plan there have
also been comments that the consultation
period forms over the summer holiday
period the minimum statutory period for
consultation is six weeks but we will be
looking at eight or even ten weeks to
give plenty of opportunity to comment
whilst I'm presenting the plan I didn't
write it so I hope you don't mind if I
direct any questions on the content of
it to Robert Hobbs finally I commend it
to you and asked for your approval to
put it out to consultation in July for a
period of ten weeks thank you Jim thank
you
could I have a seconder caps award did
you want to say anything thank you
this is now open for questions and
debate thank you council Carbondale
Thank You chair just to endorse what
councillor Aarthi has said about the
consultation period I really would like
that to go to ten weeks in order to
allow parishes that don't meet during
the summer to have a chance to give it
to due consideration councillor Hinton
Thank You chairman a couple of questions
really within the document itself it
mentions certain bits of evidence base
but we don't know what those evidence
bases are for instance the
infrastructure delivery plan will only
be made available when it goes out for
consultation so we don't know how that
impacts upon the document or whether it
makes it more valued or less valued
housing need is not covered
other than the arbitrary figures that
come from the central government and the
employment prospects across the district
because we have considerable problems
across a district with those both
employment report says that if
employment is falling and also if I go
back to infrastructure we have major
problems in terms of infrastructure
provision whether it be roads rail
doctors water everything we are
supposedly in the driest part of the
country we're supposed to be going to be
operating with reduced water consumption
for each house in the district so why
are we building loads of houses an area
where there's no water so it would be
nice to see some evidence on those and
where is their evidence and when will it
be available to us
thank you thank you very much heaven I
would first of all like to commend the
officers who have obviously been working
long hours on this I haven't heard how
many sleepless nights if you're anything
like me four o'clock in the morning is a
good time at the moment with the light
mornings I have had concerns from my
Parris's already over this and I have
directed some already here to rob hops
but there are a couple of things that I
think I need to say one is it is in a
bit of a hurry I think that we could
have had a bit more time as members to
look at it the briefing on Friday I did
appreciate but it was late noticed I
couldn't stay behind to have any
conversations with Rob because I did go
to the ballet
and it was brilliant some of my parishes
are very concerned about the
infrastructure where it says basically
it will be done but how will it be done
I have four primary schools in my area I
have one at Kok field it does have
capacity the other three don't I have
one in Lebanon that has no green space
which makes life very difficult
I also have issues about the health
provision long Melford and laudanum
surgeries which are one are not actually
taking on any more patients buildest and
I notice is going to have a huge
possible influx of people billed as the
Mabry - intervene to say that we are
only looking at policies here we're not
talking about
Vickey Awards individual award matters
can be discussed privately with the
officers sorry thank you but I'm giving
the reasons behind why I'm querying the
interesting shop it seems to me that
that does need to be a lot of more work
done on this particularly with the
infrastructure i well remember being
told last year when I was in cabinet as
the cabinet member for Communities that
we would that we were deferring this
policy this document and till we knew
where the money was coming from for this
infrastructure and that is what concerns
me would this be a good point to ask
Robert Hubbs - or counselor RC to answer
some of the questions that's been put
forward yes can we can we now move to
answering some of the questions okay
yeah I mean I think that both of those
questions were concerned with
infrastructure and I mean like the
course would draw members attention to
pages 53 54 55 the infrastructure
chapter and policy SPO 8 on page 55 and
particularly the last paragraph of that
which details how the required
infrastructure will be provided talks
about a combination of community
infrastructure levy still planning
obligations developer contributions and
where appropriate funding assistance
from the councils and other provider
organizations on the issue of the
evidence base I think that perhaps
Robert Hubbs is the best person to
answer that part of mr. Hinton's
question about what evidence base has
been used what's available and I'm
guessing that parts of council Hinton's
question was also about if people are
going to provide responses to this they
need the evidence available to make
valid responses oops could you please
the question yes Venki chair so in
respect to the evidence space there will
be an updated strategic
housing unemployment land availability
assessment published alongside the
consultation so that's one question
we're covering over 2017 document on the
website which informed the options
consultation in respect to housing need
this is a standard methodology devised
by the government which uses household
projections and applies an affordability
ratio to the calculation that's
available in the planning practice
guidance which is on online we also have
a strategic housing market assessment
which has been updated which provides
further information on housing mix and
tenure we do have an employment land
needs assessment published already on
the website from 2016 which has informed
the evolution of the plan alongside a
sector needs assessment for 2017 so
they're available now to have a look at
him we spent two the infrastructure
delivery plan that will be published
alongside the consultation and that has
been developed in collaboration with
Suffolk County Council in particular
around education and that has involved a
lot of feasibility study work about
whether schools can in fact be extended
how much they can be extended by and
what the costs are those will be
detailed in the infrastructure delivery
plan on the point about water there is a
policy LP 23 on page one one six and one
one seven of the document which seeks to
use the additional optional standard of
acquiring a hundred and ten liters per
person rather than one hundred twenty
five liters per person so we have
recognized need to have more stringent
and targets with well cut the Hinton
well chairman yeah that's all very well
but if we're going to reduce the water
consumption are we going to do it by
restricting the amount that's available
for each house how are we going to
police that and you've missed out one of
the strategic parts of infrastructure
which is road transport you look at the
route based strategy that the Highways
Agency produced in 2013 it says that it
expected that by 2:30 the Haven ports
will have 37% of the UK's total deep-sea
capacity it's clear therefore that's a
significant and growing proportion of
the UK's trades and goods particularly
in containers we'll continue to use the
Haven ports we already know between
Felixstowe and Harwich there are
something like a million truck movies a
year how felixstowe itself produces next
to 4 million on top of that of
containment trap yes
it all comes out down the roads which
according to this document says we are
going to use as the arteries for our
housing development well if we're going
to put a whole lot of domestic
householders onto those roads as well
it's going to be even worse now where
you've got four or five mile long queues
down the a12 every day so where is the
justification for putting the houses
where they are when we haven't even got
an infrastructure strategy according to
mr. Hobbs would actually even mentions
roads or strategic boat networks do you
want to come back on that Thank You
chair as we produce a plan one of our
key partners that we engage with is
highways England and with the County
Council in respect of the strategic road
network that councillor hinter refers to
and like many stakeholders they will be
the console team on this plan and we'll
have further discussions with them as
this is developed in terms of the water
that is the building regulations and the
policy that's how we're in force created
planning application system that the
requirements are required in the plan
are met
thank you Mike I just say further to
that mister hinson might want to refer
to pages 115 to 117 and again
particularly Mike let's look at the last
paragraph of policy LP 23 which does
indeed talk about achieving 100 litres
per person per day residential property
council Lindsay did you have your hand
up earlier did you have a comment okay
thank you
sorry yes I thank the council Mabry for
her remark because that chimes exactly
with what I and I think members are
group of being thinking that it's being
rushed and you know really yes I was
delighted to take part in the in the
working group and the policies I don't
you know I think we could push harder on
some of them but I'm sort of more or
less okay with that
but we didn't get the proposal maps till
a few days ago the whole reason for yes
I know there's been lots of
consultations and it's been delayed well
the reason we were told for the delay of
till after the election was to allow new
members to have their say in it now I
don't feel all our group is new I don't
feel we've had an opportunity to have
our say and reducing it to a scrum
around Robert Hobbs desk after the
briefing isn't really a good way of
going to to to look to our residents
with this document so I'd like to
propose an amendment if I may I don't
know if that's
okay so in the recommendation it says
three point one and three point two I'd
like to insert a new three point two so
that three point two becomes three point
three to see what I mean
and that would read and that the
corporate manager strategic planning
before the proposals maps are approved
for consultation reviews and where
appropriate redraws the proposals Maps
or adds caveats in consultation with any
ward member that raises concerns about
their ward by Thursday the 11th of july
2019 that might address some of the
issues that councilor Mabry and I'm sure
others tombow cooked do you have any
comments on this amendment please it's
for you check it rather depends what is
meant by adds caveats yes it would be
incredibly difficult to redraw the maps
at this stage because that would require
going back round the loop of
sustainability appraiser and would add a
significant delay into the process so
some clarification about what is meant
by adding caveats would be would be
useful to understand how deliverable
that is you'd like to come back on that
then with your sure so I mean if you
look at those things that could be those
notes to all the allocations those
little notes that say more in you know
for example improving the footpath links
to the site from X Direction extra
funding required for a health center
you know schools that so so so it was
those what I call in caviar a bit there
so if we can so that the allocation is
there but we're just asking for a bit
more detail on what we on what we're
specifying in terms of infrastructure
with those allocations so future and
it's quite difficult to envisage what
that how that would actually play out in
terms of every single set of a boundary
or every single allocation the
allocations already talked about the
infrastructure that is necessary in
order for them to be delivered so you'll
see that there are policies specific to
every single allocation as part of those
policies it says education
infrastructure would need to be improved
or health care facilities would need to
be improved and those kind of things are
already within the proposals and the
provision of sustainable infrastructure
to support the allocations is an
inherent part of why they have been put
forward and proposed as part of this
preferred options so it's not completely
clear to me what that process will
necessarily add in essence I think
mm-hmm just to remind this is a
consultation version of the plan and the
time in which councilors Tana parish
councils other stakeholders members of
your communities and individual
residents can usefully add detail into
the plan is during that consultation
process there is no harm in that coming
out through the consultation process
indeed that is the entire purpose of
this stage of the plan is for the
council to put its first preferred
option out there where the genuine
desire to engage with our local
communities and ensure that when we get
to the next stage we have a plan that
fully represents what councilors
stakeholders and the wider community
perceive is appropriate to deliver the
housing needs the economic growth and
the protection of the environment
the plan is proposing cuts wrathy have
you got well just to say a chair I'm a
little bit disappointed by councillor
Lindsay's proposal this is a strategic
document we can't have individual words
reinterpreted by the the ward members I
think he should use his skills at which
I'm sure he has many he should use his
skills to formulate a valid response to
the consultation councillors can we use
this time now to debate the amendment
Thank You chair and I've got some
sympathy with the but it's also about
these two viewpoints being presented by
councillor neighbouring councillor
Lindsey but also they seem to Vietnam at
diametric odds to each other one on the
one hand we're saying the matter has
been delayed and it has been a long time
we've been talking about the joint local
plan and another matter saying we're
acting too quickly now it can't be both
we have actually had since 2017 I've
reminded members at the briefing that
after all they said we haven't seen this
before I'm sorry many members who were
here in 2017 have had a wad of documents
presented to them showing various
options and various things we've been
through this in the previous stage of
the consultation now for the new members
those joining the council after the last
election there is time and in fact I
note that the amendment proposed is
truly Thursday of the 11th of July I
believe the consultation is actually
starting after that date anyway and the
consultation is proposed to be extended
by a further two weeks now if we're
talking about three weeks to the start
of the consultation and ten weeks of the
consultation it seems to me there's more
than sufficient time for people to catch
up to date and when I say catch up to
date I have to say that these site
allocations have not come out of the
blue members are admittedly of the
previous council but it has been in the
public domain have had the option to
look at these allocations in their
previous
versions as a strategic housing land
allocation assessment and a strategic
housing market assessment slaw and Sh'ma
respectively pardon me anyway
all I'm saying is we can't argue both
delay and that we're moving too quickly
we'd have a delay and yet we're still
moving too fast this is a document that
we need if we don't get this out we
lengthen the length of time we might not
have a local plan and therefore we
become vulnerable to speculative
applications and let's face it there are
people out there only too happy to bring
them forward the longer we delay the
longer it is that we are not able to
protect the residents of the very
communities that we represent of all
members you can't have it both ways it
needs to be done it needs to be done now
that we are the crust in the
consultation process or what the heck
are we doing anyone else on the
amendment cuts the beer thank you madam
chairman yes well I fully agree with the
last speaker this has gone on for far
too long it certainly hasn't been rushed
we're at a stage now where we're going
out for consultation only and this is
what were asking people to give their
views on and I'd respectfully say to the
members that most people who respond to
this will be people that would have an
interest in certain little areas are you
for their own areas or something that
they're involved with so these will be
picked up in those eight weeks and I
hope we take canceler cottontails
proposal to extend it to 10 weeks and I
was thinking that if that's what you're
doing which will give plenty to a plenty
of time I think to delay it now any
longer for any other reason wouldn't be
right
the safeguards are in I had some
sympathy with my colleague comes from
Avery but that will give enough time for
people members and the community who
want to comment they'll comment on their
areas mainly only and come back with
their views and I think that's what we
wanted the stage madam chairman
thank you thank you I will second your
Posen for ten weeks thank you any other
comments for debate Thank You councillor
Lindsay would like to make any further
comments just to say well it won't be
delay because as we pointed out the the
it's going to consultation after the
11th of July so I understand so we're
not talking about delay they talked
about more time for members to feed in
before it goes out no change in the date
going out to members not have that
ability already simply by being able to
speak to officers at any time cancel
I'll see anything you'd like to say on
the amendment please Thank You chairman
now I thought I think I've probably said
it thank you
oh it's award yeah it's just in response
to the last thing that castle is he said
about the date
his final date over the length of July
the problem with that is inevitably that
as I think Tom Barker has mentioned
there would be a necessity to to work on
anything that comes up in that period
the sustainability appraisal work will
probably need to be redone and it'll
have a huge knock-on effect on on the
ability to start the public consultation
on the 22nd of July and we really don't
want to do that I cannot see that
there's anything that can be achieved in
this intervening period between now and
the 11th of July that cannot be achieved
during that main consultation period and
we've really as council McCourt McCraw
has eloquently explained we really do
not want or can afford to have any
further delay in this thank you Thank
You counsel ward okay I think we're
ready to move to a vote on the amendment
all those in favor of the amendment
please please show
for those against the amendment is lost
can we return to the originals proposal
please has anyone got any comments on
the original proposal please cancel a
beer period can we change that to ten
wheat as councillor Cottondale asked for
and about 10 weeks was my proposal I
heard the recommendations to put in a
consultation in July for a period of 10
weeks well done fine thank you
any other comments before we move to the
vote council Mabry Thank You chairman um
there is one comment that I would like
to make and if you wish to look at page
74 it will help you I was absolutely
delighted to hear and the Rudd MP on BBC
TV this morning talking about disability
friendly homes this is something that I
have raised at every opportunity and our
chief executive will back me on that
this is something that we desperately
need and it's not just for the older
generations
it is for those people who find
themselves in a situation that they
never ever expected so I'm delighted
that as I call it my homes for life will
be in this document thank you thank you
can't sir Busby did you have a comment
thank Jay
yeah I think one of the concerns that a
lot of our villages will have is that
the amount of building that we're going
to be doing out they might change the
character of the towns and villages and
I think one of the principles that we
should put in here is that we will aim
to protect or at least in or enhance the
character of our towns and villages I
think it's crucial it defines baver to
what it is each village is different and
I think each village wants to stay
different it doesn't want to be swamped
by a different type of housing different
type of development so I think that's an
important principle that we should put
in thank you thank you
cuts Rossi would you like to comment on
that I wasn't actually going to comment
on that I was going to respond to
counselor Mabry yes and just say yes I
absolutely agree with her and in the
working groups it was something that
generated quite a lot of discussion
support for that policy
because I got something cool Thank You
chef I'd like to propose we move
straight to the proposal this is a
consultation we could do talked
endlessly on this that's what the
consultations for let the people speak
and we will listen do you have a
seconder for that so for clarification
we're just going to add two point three
one of the recommendation that we will
be having a 10-week consultation period
so all in all those in favor of the
recommendations please PLEASE show
carried sorry no sorry they all those
again this please three three against
thank you so then that's carried thank
you so we'll move on now to item 9 BC
nineteen eight publication of the Weber
housing delivery test action plan I
would like to invite council Aarthi
cabinet member for planning to introduce
paper BC nineteen eight and to move the
recommendations in the report thank you
Thank You chairman yes this will be a
little bit shorter for my presentation
just a few little points the housing
delivery test hdt was published in
February 2000 and nineteen and it
identified baby districts as achieving
eighty eight percent of the total number
of dwellings required over the period
first of April 2015 to the 31st of March
2018 as a consequence of not meeting
ninety-five percent of the housing
requirement the council is required to
publish a housing delivery test action
plan within six months from February
2019 so that by August of 2019 we should
incorporate a range of measures that
will support increased housing delivery
if you've had a chance to to read at all
and it was quite a document I would
first highlight to you the general
recommendations which are on page 43 and
page 44 particularly paragraphs three
points for
and 3:25 and especially the 15 bullet
points on page 44 so if you've all
followed that I have a paper copy here
there are the 15 actually numbered the
15 bullet points under under 3.5 finally
I'd also like to bring your attention to
the sill section which is on page 38
that's two point four five to two point
four nine in the round this is something
that we have to do and it's been done
and I propose the recommendations for
its adoption
thank you sir Davis thank you the ward
Thank You Jay what I think this paper
fully justifies why we need to get on as
quickly as possible and produce a new
joint Local Plan we need to have the
ability to bring forward sites that are
deliverable and so we don't end up in a
position where we fail to deliver and
have to produce action plans like this
and not reduce the numbers that we have
as our targets this is a good document
and it gives us a framework for for
working forward and and understanding
why we have stalled sites and actions to
to turn that we can take place to to
resolve them but we do need to proceed
with our plan so that we don't end up in
a situation where we're forever having
to look back and and review why things
have been stalled at least we'll have
sites in the future that we can take
forward in the full certainty that we
know that they are deliverable and that
the infrastructure will be there too
thank you any further questions or
comments councillor Hinton Thank You
Sharon just a quick one and it does talk
about the data was cancerous he's
already said that the we are 88 88
percent or something compliant with this
it also says that the data was produced
for the hdt ap focusing on major housing
developments on sites of 10 dwellings
and above how many houses did we build
outside of 10 homes and other words
smaller than 10 homes and what would
that have done to the overall figure but
I suspect that it would probably have
done quite a lot because a lot of our
development across the district is in
smaller sites and 10 homes even chairman
I'm sure there is an answer to that
question no I'm gonna look to Robert
hopes to see if he has it at him thank
you for you chair and the 88 percent
refers to all dwellings the 80 percent
refers to all dwellings not just major
developers the future their housing
delivery test time action plan focuses
on delivery of major to balances that
these ones are where we need to
understand more how those developers
come forward but in terms of the actual
figures that provided the government
that go into the house of delivery test
all completions over the past three
years go into that calculation into so
madam chairman we can assume that
paragraph 4.4 is completely incorrect in
this report could excessive dart was
produced for the HTTP a focusing on
major housing on sites of 10 dwellings
and above well obviously if it's applies
to all dwellings then we're not we're
doing a different set of criteria to the
what the government was requiring us to
um Robert Hubbs do you have a comment on
that can you come back on that Thank You
chair yes the data for the housing to
retest action plan which is what we're
talking about here was focusing on
majors of elements of ten dwellings or
more to have some delivery test results
which the action plan follows from looks
at every single completion as I've just
said so that's where the 88 percent
comes from since two separate sizes one
is the housing delivery test which sets
out what the percentage is we have to
follow and then as counsel Alfie alluded
to because papers delivery was less than
95 percent an action plan therefore
needed to be produced and in producing
the action plan we specifically focused
on develop save attend weddings in terms
of what can be done to make sure that
the delivery is continued Cal siharan
Chairman yes thank you
um page 44 for it they're not numbered
but for up from the bottom something
that struck me a couple of days ago
compulsory purchase orders is this a
threat orders are we suggesting that we
genuinely buy up half of Chilton to get
that planning application moving and
does somebody know where the money might
come from just a bit of clarification
please clarify this Thank You chair and
this was identified also freely the
homes and housing strategy which was
adopted by council and effectively what
is identifying is that is one mechanism
that can be used but that would require
a further exploration at this stage
capsule award
it's a cabinet member finance I can
assure castle Heron I don't think we've
quite got the money to buy a half of
Chilton but seriousness is this an idle
threat or could we really do it Kyle did
you want to come back on this he wants
an answer we could but I'm sure we won't
cancel Busby thank you thanks Jeff what
are the big problems that we have with
development stalling is it's down to the
developer primarily the question we have
to ask ourselves is what do we do to
encourage the developer to develop that
sort when they've probably got the
handful of others around the county that
they could do rather than ours to me the
the two things that are missing in here
to encourage development from stalling
is one we should be building more houses
ourselves if we were building to 300 of
the 400 houses that we require of 500
houses required we wouldn't be so
dependent upon the developers we can
start then saying to developers that Lee
you need to build these out or you're
not gonna get Planning Commission we're
not desperate to have those developments
come through but on the other side of
the coin if we're building war council
houses or affordable houses we don't
need the developments to do it we
shouldn't be asking I don't believe
developers to contribute 35% affordable
housing why should they take that kind
of hit on their profit if we reduce that
because we built the houses ourselves to
10% suddenly our sites are more
favorable than all the ones around the
county that are demanding 35% we have to
look at how do we encourage the
developers to build the sites and
those two things I don't think are in
here we should build more houses
ourselves and reduce the affordable
housing content because where else is
there something you'd like to come back
on well yeah I mean I don't think
necessarily build the houses ourselves
I don't quite see that as an answer I
mean I'm not quite sure if mr. buzzby is
sort of saying well we should go in and
compulsory purchase the site and build a
mall the council house the other
suggestion but as far as addressing the
issue of stall sites with developers
like that I think the the answer to that
the proposed solutions to that problem
are on page 42 and 43 and indeed when
we're looking at sites where they have
been stalled for some time that's on
page 43 the Big C just after the top of
the page solution three late-stage
dollars you will see there but what we
need to do is engage with all developers
to try and understand what is needed to
ensure that the Commission gets built
out so I mean this engagement with
developers is fundamental to the
recommendations in here if executives
would like to say something here
I think thanks Jim just in relation to
councillor Busby's question I just want
to add the first aspect of your question
page 44 about halfway down that list of
bullet points yeah developing new
private homes through council owned
housing companies and developing 240 new
council houses in Weber so part of your
your request I suppose ease in there the
second aspect more relates to the joint
local plan but to some extent you said
it's half way down a list of bullet
points that are for the key points
committee if that should be the major
statement if we're going to build fifty
percent of all our housing requirement
that should be a you know that should be
right up front it isn't it's half way
down a set of bullet points but you know
they're nice and flowery and Clyde
that's that's
we're going to talk to developers that's
not a solution that's a point down the
pub on a Friday night it's not a
solution
we shouldn't be in a document tells the
world
yeah actually Council but I just wanted
to pick up on on what the chief
executive said if you turn to page 47
items 8 & 9 you'll see it covers both
the private homes that we want to
develop through our own housing company
but and also the HRA homes that we want
to build it's got numbers in there these
are numbers that we've looked at and we
believe are achievable your targets
greatness an aspiration but we need to
work out what we can really afford but
being no mistake we do have aspirations
plans to build both open market and
affordable housing through through the
general fund and also through the
housing revenue account so we are trying
to do this as much as we can with the
money we have available but we're not
going to be able to produce build the
numbers that you're talking about we
will we are going to require private
developers to provide the lion share of
house building in the districts custom
accrual thanks chair just a couple of
points of clarification am I correct in
thinking that this is a legal
requirement of this council that we have
to do this and second is it likely to be
improved in any appreciable way by our
spending a long time talking about it
no but I'm just conscious of the fact
that frankly that the words blindingly
obvious seem to come to mind we have a
Chinook we in fact in fact we have to
deliver a document according to the
principles that the government have in
their infinite wisdom decided we should
and then we have to try and make it
stick and yes I appreciate all the
points made it is not within our gift
but we have to put something down we
can't just say we're going to take them
down the pub for example we have to be
able to come up with some actual
structured arguments that will meet the
test that is required for our own
housing delivery test action plan and I
suggest that that's what we've done here
and we shouldn't waste any more time on
this do you think we're ready for a
baked won't take up a lot of time but
just one of the things that does spring
to mind is the top of page 31 where it
talks about builders are in a position
to exercise control over sales rates as
rivals are limited in their opportunity
to offer customers different types of
housing tenure well as long as the
builders are in control we're screwed
so are we making any swords to
government to allow us to put something
on a planning permission that gives us
the ability to force a developer to get
on with it
because Aarthi did you want to make any
comment 'i'd i rate that more as a
statement of fact an action and I think
it's a fair statement of fact I think
we're ready to move on now can we move
to the vote
can I have people show forth emotion
please can I now see those against the
recommendation please and any
abstentions I think we have one
abstention
thank you it's carried now on to item 10
BC
19-9 nominations for appointment of
directors to the broad of BDC Suffolk
Holdings Limited I would like to invite
councillor Busby vice chair BDC Suffolk
Holdings Limited to introduce paper BC
19 9 and to move the recommendation in
the report
Thank You counsel Thank You chair I've
made a few notes no this report proposes
the election of two new directors
something I'll say
counselor John Hinton and countess
Elizabeth
mell VZ to the board of Baylor District
Council Suffolk Holdings to fill posts
which were vacated by former councilors
nickridley and Allen Ferguson the
election of new directors to the holding
company will ensure robust governance of
the company structure is retained and it
says here that I'll look forward to the
opportunity of working with them both on
the holding board
that's what it says here so Kai proposed
that thing thank you can I have a
seconder Thank You councillor hole say
anything thank you to the folk then
please so those for accepting these
thank you
thank you it's carry item items 11 and
12 appointment of substitute to the
shared revenues partnership committee
and counselor appointments I'm taking
items 11 and 12 together Lita these
items have been tabled in the papers
tonight are there any other changes
please
councillor Ward yes just wanted to
inform members that there was an
omission at the list of appointments
that we've proved our last council
meeting and I just wanted to add that
counselor Owen will be one of the
representatives on the Gypsy and
traveler steering group which I believe
you are already aware of so thank you
thank you we don't need to take a vote
on this the recommendations simply for
noting so we'll move on thank you item
13 has been withdrawn so I think we're
ready to close the meeting
thank you the next meeting is Tuesday
23rd July at 5:30 thank you and have a
good evening